if you were my
investment advisor and i was trying to
invest in the future
uh how do you think the human species
is most likely to destroy itself in
this century uh yeah in uh so
if if the crisis many of the crisis
we're facing are really before us within
the
next hundred years how do we uh
make explicit the make known the
the unknowns and solve those problems to
to avoid the biggest
uh um starting with the biggest
existential crisis so as your investment
advisor how are you planning to make
money on us
destroying ourselves i have to ask i
don't know it's uh it might be the
russian origins
somehow involved at the micro level of
detailed strategies of course this is
these are unsolved problems
for ai alignment we can break it into
three sub-problems that are all unsolved
i think with you know you want first to
make machines
understand our goals then adopt our
goals
and then retain our goals so
to hit on all three real quickly
the problem when andreas lubitz told his
autopilot to fly into the alps
was that the computer didn't even
understand anything about
his goals right it was too dumb it could
have understood actually
but we would have had to put some effort
in as a
systems designer don't fly into
mountains
so that's the first challenge how do you
how do you program into computers
human values human goals we can start
rather than than saying oh it's so hard
we should start with the simple stuff as
i said
self-driving cars airplanes just put in
all the goals that we all agree on
already
and then have a habit of whenever
machines get smarter so they can
understand one level higher goals you
know
put them into the second challenge is
getting them to adopt the goals it's
easy for situations like that where you
just program it in but when you have
self-learning systems like children you
know
any parent knows that
there's a difference between getting our
kids to understand what we want them to
do and to actually
adopt our goals right with with humans
with
children fortunately they
they go through this phase first they're
too dumb to understand what we want
our goals are and then they have this
period of
some years when they're both smart
enough to understand them and malleable
enough that we have a chance to
raise them well and then they become
teenagers
late but we have this window with
machines the challenges they might
the intelligence might grow so fast that
that window is pretty short
so that's that's the research problem
the third one is how do you make sure
they keep the goals
if they keep learning more and getting
smarter
many sci-fi movies are about how you
have something which initially was a
line but then
things kind of go off keel and you know
my kids
were very very excited about their legos
when they were little
now they're just gathering dust in the
basement you know if we put if we create
machines that are really
on board with a goal of taking care of
humanity we don't want them to get as
bored with us and
and as my kids go with legos
so this is another research challenge
how can you make some sort of
recursively self-improving system retain
certain basic goals that said a lot of
adult people still play with legos so
maybe we succeeded with the legos
i like your optimism not all ai systems
have to maintain the goals right some
just some fraction yeah so there so
there's a there's a lot of um
talented ai researchers now who have
heard of this and want to work on it
not so much funding for it yet uh
of the billions that go into building a
ai more powerful
it's only a minuscule fraction so far
going into the safety research
my attitude is generally we should not
try to slow down the technology but we
should greatly accelerate the investment
in this sort of safety research
and also make sure it's been it's this
was very embarrassing last year but
you know the nsf decided to give out the
six of these big institutes we got one
of them for ai and science
you asked me about another one was
supposed to be for ai safety research
and they gave it people studying oceans
and climate and stuff
yeah so i'm all for starting oceans and
climates but we need to actually
have some money that actually goes into
ai safety research also and doesn't just
get grabbed by whatever
that's a fantastic investment and then
at the higher level
you ask this question okay what can we
do you know what are the biggest risks
i think i think we cannot just consider
this to be only a technical problem
like again because if you solve only the
technical problem
can i play with your robot yes please if
we just
get our machines you know to just
blindly obey
the orders we give them so we can always
trust that it will do what we want
that might be great for the owner of the
robot that might not be so great for the
rest of humanity if
if that person is that least favorite
world leader or whatever you
imagine right so we have to also take
look at the apply alignment not just to
machines
but to all the other powerful structures
that's why it's so important to
strengthen our democracy again as i said
to have institutions
make sure that the playing field is not
rigged so that
corporations are given the right
incentives to do the things
that both make profit and are good for
people
to make sure that countries have
incentives to do things that are both
good for their people
and don't screw up the rest of the world
and this is not just something for ai
nerds you know to geek out on this is
the
interesting challenge for political
scientists economists and
so many other thinkers
you